i'm sure you saw uh
was it ll got into the rock and roll
hall of fame that's right he got
inducted right he got inducted and he
shot him he shouted you out just about a
month now right yeah it's about a month
ago and he shouted you out in the speech
which i thought was dope because in my
opinion
top three
battles as a kid
i remember obviously second round
knockout
and i remember going and buying dmx's
it's dark and hell is hot the bonus disc
version because the second there was a
there was a def jam version of that
album that had a
bonus disc in it that had the the ripper
strikes back on it right right yeah
that's right
and um i just remember knowing both of
those records by heart and just thinking
like damn like i like just it was such a
just an epic time uh epic battle but i
always felt like there was always
respect and i thought it was it's just
so dope to see all these years later ll
just show you some love you know i mean
it's a shame that we didn't wwf it right
and what i mean by that is like
like why couldn't
there have been some wise elder right
to come out and just say all right
listen man
you guys kissing makeup right now right
but on the screen yeah yeah yeah do that
and let's all really just get rich and
let's let's go ahead and create to do
this take this template and do it every
time rap artists get into beef instead
for us
there was no wwf they put everybody in
the situation like this is real
you can't sleep tonight because you got
dissed you know what i'm saying you
can't show your face because you got
dissed right you're under pressure
because you got dissed
you you know what i mean you're not
you're not the artist that we all
thought you were because you got dissed
like hip-hop kind of did a number on the
both of us i think and every artist
thereafter and before they got into you
know disagreements with each other
there was no at no time
during on my watch was i able to witness
someone that was wise coming into the
fray right and saying
you know what there's a way to wwf this
before everyone gets paid that's right
that's right we take our rapper hats off
at the end of the night never happened
yeah never happened so that's how i look
at the whole thing i don't everything
y'all talking about what y'all saying to
me man it's chinese
because what what what everybody else is
talking about is something that still we
spent what five minutes talking about
this so far it makes no money right
nobody gets anything from it
but on the wwf side of things
they eat bro
[Music]
and i'm not slow yeah and i'm not slow
so i kind of feel i kind of feel i feel
insulted i feel like
i got stuck with the dummies
you know i mean i got put into the genre
and music
got had to get to do that with the
dummies you know what i mean i should
have been on another side where it's
like you know somebody the wise man
comes down off the off the mountain he's
got the plan and he says i like what you
guys just did you know what
let's go get some money with it instead
on this side of things almost like a
paul heyman that's right let's do it but
on this side of thing with rap
the guy comes off the top of the
mountain and says man
you won't believe what he said to me
about you up there man if i was you i go
up to you see what i'm trying to say i
hear what you're saying and then they
just wipe us out we wipe ourselves out
and i and i'm i'm confused as to how
nobody has can see it yet yeah i mean
and if and hey look there might be
situations that we just aren't privy to
where that might have happened you know
i don't know i just don't think that
we'd ever be exposed i love you bro
that's [ __ ] no i don't know i don't
know i mean the way word of mouth goes
on and rap no you're right it's a bunch
of gossiping bro yeah so when you but
when you when you heard him shout you
out like i mean obviously that was the
phone went crazy yeah the texts were
crazy you know um
[Music]
you know i was
i didn't remember what i was doing at
the time oh i was writing i was writing
for kaiju wow i was writing i was
writing i was i was vocaling right i was
vocaling and i put the phone on airplane
mode so when it took it off it was like
everything went crazy yeah and then i
was like oh man oh just you know i'm
stupid i'm thinking it's something
stupid right i think he got up there and
said yo man i won't see cannabis in the
pine box you understand what i'm saying
i'm just telling you right what i
thought when i looked at it and then
when i heard it was the opposite
you know it did feel good
you know now wow now wow now while of
course
you know what if i was like stuck
somewhere in south africa
right and i couldn't get back to the
states or right what if i'd been human
trafficked somewhere right
think about this right what if i was
somewhere else
unable to communicate back right but i
heard about that
how you supposed to feel um you're not
supposed to feel like this shout out
is any kind of guiding light from the
creator like you you know just hang in
there kid you're at it right right
then this is not the way that rap i feel
in the beginning
this is not the way that it was meant
to
uh develop
i don't feel that way because
every other
the word team
the word genre the word group
the word uh
i mean just any synonym to you know like
like a
group right right people
right any other synonym is going to you
look up the examples or you look up
something that's comparable you're gonna
see that
we don't leave nobody behind
you know what i mean all right you know
what
we keep our scuffles inside the family
you know what i mean everybody all
that's got to be paid so forth and so on
but you know what we don't leave nobody
behind man
rap
bro
i'm i'm i'm good man i'm good because
you know what i mean i got other things
doing working right but for those who
don't
you gotta you got a guest list so long
and rap of people that could come up
here and talk about being left behind
yeah i'm telling you bro i mean no 100
it's not something right with that
picture man i agree i mean i'm not here
to fix it either but nobody's true but
you're right you're right so don't so i
don't want anybody to come talk to me
like i'm slow about
a shout out or something like that i'm
not miserable about it i'm saying it
don't don't even waste my time man you
know what i mean about something that
it doesn't mean anything you understand
i get it